bonsoir le 18 décembre 2000
lécluse juste au dessus à deux ponts sur
leur sur le canal jean rochefort avait
répondu à l'appel de l'association des
enfants de don quichotte et il était
venu surtout exprimé son indignation à
l'idée qui est des gens qui dorment dans
la rue à paris dans des tentes de
fortune et je voudrais vous lire
rapidement ce que ce qu'ils disaient à
l'occasion faut l'imaginer avec la voix
inimitable de genre je crois ça doit
vraiment disparaître et le plus vite
possible
il faut ce que ces gens là et le plus
vite possible à domicile
tout ça n'est pas possible j'ai passé
quelques décennies sur la planète
celle là je la révolte maintenant c'est
dire merde je vais pas partir alors que
tout cela perdure c'est pas possible
merde je vais pas partir alors que tout
ça perdure c'est pas possible
genre soir est mort en octobre dernier
et si vous avez descendu le canal pour
venir les tendres sont toujours là il ya
deux ans je cherchais un nouveau projet
de recherche et j'avais envie d'aller
dans quelque chose de plus concret que
ce qui était face à moi à l'époque qui
était un long projet de recherche sur
les défilés de mode et la fashion week
et voulant sortir un peu du glamour je
regardais dans l'actualité quelque chose
qui ait du sens et malheureusement il y
avait deux choses qui dominait
l'actualité à ce moment là la crise des
réfugiés est un triste record qui était
celui du nombre de sans abri morts dans
la rue en france on en était à 500 à
l'époque et j'ai eu envie de travailler
sur les deux sujets il y en a un qui m'a
mené vers les camps de réfugiés au liban
en syrie et récemment avec l'héroïne
gars du bangladesh
mais ce dont je voudrais vous parler ce
soir c'est c'est les sdf ce que l'abbé
pierre appelait avec avec amour et avec
humour les couches dehors qui sont
encore toujours là d'ailleurs j'emprunte
à l'abbé pierre le sous titre de ma
présentation et j'en reparlerai tout à
l'heure sur cette idée d'une
insurrection de la bonté et je m'inspire
du titre d'un titre d' hannah arendt sur
lequel je reviendrai
tout à l'heure je n'habite pas en france
j'ai le le privilège
le plaisir d'habiter dans une ville
britannique magnifique qui est la ville
d'oxford qui existe autour d'une
université médiévale ce qui fait que
juste derrière chez moi il ya ces
bâtiments la st john's collège par
exemple construit au xiiie siècle et sur
ces photos qu'on qu'on trouve sur tous
les sites internet de de tous les deux
tout l'université d'oxford il manque
deux choses premièrement c'est en
angleterre donc il fait pas toujours ce
temps là il fait ce temps là toujours
magnifique toujours médiéval un peu gris
un peu plus vieux un peu froid il manque
une autre chose c'est que
proportionnellement la ville d'oxford
est une des villes qui a le plus de sdf
en grande bretagne et c'est eux dont je
voudrais parler parce que on les voit
pas sur la carte postale ils
disparaissent des photos mais c'est eux
qui sont le plus marquant si on fait un
tout petit peu attention à la ville
d'oxford l'angleterre à une population
croissante de sdf
ils sont comme nous ils ont du mal à
faire face aux problèmes parfois
malheureusement pour des raisons
totalement cosmétique
imaginez que vous ayez un mariage royal
dans les rues de londres forcément ça
fait un peu tâche et sur les selphy des
touristes à oxford
c'est sûr que sdf ça fait pas bien non
plus donc aujourd'hui la ville d'oxford
a laissé passer des amendes de 2500
livres sterling pour ces gens qui
avaient l'outrecuidance de ne pas avoir
les moyens de dormir quelques pas 2500
livres sterling c'est dérisoire en même
temps la france est et par un pays
modèle non plus on a eu des débats
récemment sur le nombre de gens qui
dormaient dans la rue à paris qui a
donné lieu à cette nuit de la solidarité
certes très politique mais qui avait un
avantage
c'était d'être capable de répondre à la
question de combien de personnes dorment
dans la rue chaque nuit à paris trois
mille 3000 le chiffre varie évidemment
450 dans le 10e arrondissement et vous
pouvez en trouver une centaine si vous
remontez le canal entre ici et
stalingrad la fondation l'abbé pierre
justement à identifier que sur les dix
dernières années
la population de sdf avait augmenté de
50% cent cinquante 150 % sur les dix
dernières années ça valait le coup en
tout cas pour moi et pour une collègue
avec laquelle je travaille and jane ans
qui est à l'université paris sud
ça nous a donné envie de travailler sur
sur ce phénomène là est un des grands
avantages de notre métier c'est que
quand on commence à travailler sur un
sujet faut qu'on lise énormément un
travailleur solitaire parfois ennuyeux
les étudiants qui sont en train d'écrire
leur mémoire en ce moment savent quelque
chose
mais un désavantage que ça c'est que on
doit aller rencontrer les gens on doit
aller sur le terrain ça m'a donné
l'occasion d'aller discuter avec des
personnes qui dorment dans la rue avec
des personnes qui sont sorties de la rue
d'anciens sans abri avec des acteurs
d'associations des ong avec des
travailleurs sociaux et d'aller au
contact de tous ces gens là a eu un
impact sur moi que je voudrais partager
avec vous et puis après je voudrais vous
parler un peu de l'impact que cela a pu
avoir sur mes pauvres cobayes des
étudiants en troisième année
une journée qui m'a marqué et à laquelle
on a pu avoir accès grâce à grâce à ma
collègue john en c le recueil social de
la ratp faut savoir que la ratp depuis
les années 90 à une cellule spécifique
dédié à se confronter à essayer
d'accompagner essayer de prendre en
charge les la population de sans abri
aujourd'hui c'est une soixantaine de
personnes qui travaillent sur sur trois
créneaux qui sont la journée la petite
nuit et la grande nuit vous les
reconnaîtrez facilement
ils ont agi les marrons et il essaye de
faire en sorte que les sdf est un
endroit où aller la ratp fait beaucoup
la ratp finances cofinance organise
co-organise structure un grand nombre
d'institutions en région parisienne pour
accueillir cette population de sans abri
passé une journée avec eux c'est
extrêmement marquant c'est extrêmement
intéressant parler avec des gens qui ne
font que ça pas avec des grands discours
pas avec des grandes actions avec
simplicité
ça remet en place ça fait un peu de bien
et surtout sa marque et je me suis
surpris dans les jours et les semaines
qui ont suivi à avoir une attention et
des réflexes que j'avais pas avant et je
vous rassure que j'ai perdu depuis
et puis j'aurais passé une journée avec
eux et ça revient
c'est que c'est facile de passer devant
des sdf est pas les regarder voire de
les enjambées de temps en temps on donne
une pièce mais vous remarquerez que des
fois on donne une pièce mais sans même
regarder la personne on jette ça dans le
récipient qui est devant on dit pas
bonjour pas au revoir on se plaindra
après qu'ils nous disent pas merci
et on évite le contact il ya quelque
chose qui se passe c'est qu'on a essayé
on essaye de s'anesthésier de mettre à
distance
ces personnes là même quand on va au
contact même quand on donne quelque
chose
et d'ailleurs quand on a rien on regarde
nos pompes fait semblant de regarder
quelles stations en est le plan du métro
on essaye de s'échapper de cette
interaction là qui nous fait un peu peur
et à chaque fois que je passe du temps
avec ces gens là avec des travailleurs
sociaux chaque fois je passe du temps au
contact de ces sans abri je me sens
derrière n'ont pas bien non pas généreux
non pas vertueux mais plus au contact
plus éveillés et plus dérangé ça
déséquilibre mais peut-être qu'on a
besoin de ce déséquilibre de ce
déséquilibre est un peu parce que enfin
on a un problème
les gens meurent de froid dans les rues
dans un pays riche aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'il faut qu'on arrête avec notre petit
confort équilibré ça m'avait rappelé la
manière dont hannah arendt caractériser
un adolf eichmann qu'elles montent elles
suivaient le procès qui était un
fonctionnaire nazis et suivait son
procès en 1961 jérusalem et elle disait
ça de lui que c'était un petit homme
totalement normal tout le monde voulait
y voir quelqu'un de diabolique et lé
livre quelqu'un qui au fil des mois et
des années a perdu le besoin de sentir
quoi que ce soit c'est pas seulement
qu'il a perdu le sentiment
il a perdu le besoin de sentir et ça
fait toujours un peu mal d'avoir une
phrase à propos d'un nazi qui vous
rappelle vos travers mais une fois de
plus c'était peut-être un déséquilibre
nécessaire
donc je me suis dit que j'allais
déséquilibré mais étudiants dans le
court affectueusement nommée achevée au
308 sociologie de l'entreprise en
troisième année ici j'ai proposé aux
étudiants de 2 e n'aurait pas proposé je
leur est imposée de parler de larmes du
travailleur pauvre c'est vers ces gens
qui ont un contrat qui ont un emploi
mais qui ont des difficultés à trouver
un logement voire n'ont pas de logement
fixe voire d'hommes dans la rue les gens
qui travaillent toute la journée puis
qui dorment dans le métro vont dans un
foyer pour prendre une douche et puis
vont travailler le lendemain en tant que
futurs managers
il me semblait important de noter que de
plus en plus de gens étaient confrontés
à ça aujourd'hui avoir un emploi avoir
un emploi stable
ça ne garantit plus d'être protégés de
la misère et si on cumule les chiffres
qu'il faut toujours prendre avec des
pincettes
près de 300 abris sur 10 ou un emploi
plus ou moins stable et sûr ces trois
sur dix y en a 40 % qui sont en cdi ça
veut dire qu'il ya un sdf sur dix qui
travaillent de près ou de loin ont cédé
c'est pas anodin comme chiffres mais vu
que j'avais envie de les secouer un peu
plus je me suis pas contenté de leur
dire ça je leur ai donné un devoir par
groupes de deux ou trois vous allez
allez rencontrer un sdf dans la rue et
vous aller retracer sa trajectoire
professionnelle depuis son enfance
jusqu'à aujourd'hui par où il est passé
par où elle est passée qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sa demande est de passer une
demi heure trois quarts d'heure une
heure avec une personne sans abri
certains ils sont allés en traînant des
pieds on peut pas leur en vouloir c'est
pas un devoir évident en école de
commerce
encore moins mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est comment ils en sont revenus et je
voudrais juste vous lire très rapidement
un extrait d'un rapport d'une des des
étudiantes
elle était allée rencontrer une sans
abri
pas très loin d'ici qui s'appelle
ibrahima c'est
avec le coeur lourd que nous avons
quitté ibrahim à rentrer chez moi je me
suis empressé de raconter cette
rencontre à ma famille je me suis rendu
compte de la chance que j'ai la réalité
de la vie m'a rattrapé ce jour là toutes
ces personnes que je croise tous les
jours qui me paraissent est banale et
qui pourtant on a un présent si lourd je
m'endormirai tous les soirs en ayant une
pensée pour une pensée pour ceux qui
sont en situation d'exclusion et de
précarité
je sais pas si elle a continué pendant
des semaines et des mois à avoir une
pensée tous les soirs mais si elle l'a
fait pendant quelques jours forcément
elle aussi comme moi elle a eu un peu de
mal à enjamber un sdf en regardant
ailleurs d'aller au contact de ces gens
là de les rencontrer de rencontrer les
gens ça impose quelque chose ça nous
déséquilibre ça nous fait bouger mais
c'est un déséquilibre nécessaire notre
équilibre est souvent une manière de
cacher notre confort auquel on est très
attachés confort qui se fait au
détriment de la rencontre avec l'autre
histoire de pousser encore un peu dans
le court parce que je trouvais qu'ils
s'étaient un peu reposé jusque là la
dernière séance était consacrée à un
documentaire qui s'appelle comme tout le
monde que je vous conseille qui fait le
portrait de quatre sans abri l'équipe du
tournage nous a fait le plaisir de venir
pour discuter avec les étudiants et on a
fait la surprise aux étudiants ils sont
venus avec trois des quatre sans abri
pour qu'ils puissent poser des questions
michael kenny loubna là vous pouvez voir
kanye et lubna j'ai pas trouvé de photos
de michael sont passés ont fait passer
une demi heure ça a duré une heure et
quart à échanger à discuter les
étudiants ont été remarquables de
respect mais aussi de curiosité de
sincérité ils ont osé poser des
questions qu'on n'ose trop rarement
posée qui peuvent paraître naïve mais
mais mais qu'il faudrait qu'on se pose
ça vous manque le confort est ce que
vous avez des relations amoureuses
comment vous faites pas avoir des
relations sexuelles c'est pas évident
comme questions et les sans abri je leur
avais dit vous avez le droit de répondre
comme vous voulez vous avez aussi le
droit de réponse que vous n'avez pas le
droit que vous avez pas envie de
répondre à ces questions là ils ont joué
le jeu ils ont répondu on devait
terminer à 19h30
les étudiants sont restés jusqu'à 20h15
faire rester des étudiants après 19
30 c'est pas évident les étudiants ont
traîné après discuter avec les sdf ont
pris des numéros d'associations certains
sont allés faire des maraudes certains
sont inquiétés de ce qui était devenu la
personne qu'ils avaient rencontré un des
groupes y retourner a pas réussi à
retrouver la personne s'est inquiété
s'est renseigné a réussi à retracer et
été rassurés de m'envoyer un mail en
disant c'est bon on l'a retrouvé il va
bien il ya quelque chose de naïf il ya
quelque chose de touchant mais en même
temps est-ce que c'est pas choquant que
cette naïveté et que cette pulsion la de
rencontre on est autant perdu une fois
qu'on rencontre
ces personnes là une fois qu'on discute
avec l une de ces personnes là celle que
vous voulez on les regarde
on les voit et apparaît le visage qui
est extrêmement important chez chez
emmanuel levinas philosophe français qui
pour qui la relation éthique et la
pulsion de responsabilité une pulsion
qu'il qui pour lui était infini passer
par le visage le visage s'impose à moi
sans que je puisse cesser d'être
responsable de sa misère la conscience
perse après sa première place
l'idée qu' on est au centre du monde que
notre confort est plus important que
celui des autres que notre équilibre est
plus important que celui des autres
disparaît au moment où on fait l'effort
de rencontrer l'autre de rencontrer la
personne c'est pas évident
ça fait bouger
ça laisse une trace penser à cette
étudiante qui à ce moment là déclare que
tous les soirs elle se couchera en ayant
une pensée pour les personnes en
situation d'exclusion
ça peut faire sourire mais en même temps
est-ce que c'est pas choquant qu'on
aille se coucher tous les soirs sans
avoir une pensée pour des gens qui
dorment dehors il ya quelque chose de
bizarre dans cette anesthésie là et ça
me fait revenir à hannah arendt et même
si c'est toujours un parallèle qui est
douloureux à faire pour l art n ya pas
de mal absolu
il n'y a pas de mal à radical
adolf eichmann n'est pas diabolique il
est banal il est normal là où le mâle
peut s'installer ça n'est pas parce
qu'il ya une personne diabolique mais
parce que nous sommes tous prêts à
rentrer dans cette banalité cette
tranquillité ce confort pour elle la
banalité du mal c'est le refus de juger
c'est quand on se met à distance c'est
quand on se donne pas les moyens de voir
deux rencontres et d'observer faute
d'imagination
faute d'avoir présent devant les yeux et
de prendre en considération les autres
on se met à distance de manière à ne pas
voir et comme ça on se protège ce que je
voudrais vous proposer c'est d'essayer
d'inverser les choses et de rentrer dans
une banalité du bien par vais pas avec
des grandes actions pas avec des grands
défis mais avec simplement le fait de
refuser d'être anesthésié aller au
contact à les rencontrer
alors je vais pas vous donner des
devoirs mal même pouvoir sur vous que
sur mes étudiants les murs sont obligés
de faire ce que je leur dit de faire
mais essayez ça en rentrant ce soir
parce que malheureusement il n'y a pas
une seule personne ici qui ne va pas
rentrer ce soir en croisant une personne
sans abri essayer d'avoir de la monnaie
si vous n'avez pas de la monnaie venait
d'emprunter
si j'ai pas j'ai plus de monnaie sur moi
on se tournera vers fils et bastien qui
sera ravi de contribuer et quand vous
croisez cette personne-là accroupissez
vous c'est quelque chose que m'ont dit
les gens du recueil social mais qu'en
fait est fondamental c'est des gens qui
sont souvent assis par terre
et quand on se penche vers eux il ya
quelque chose de très violents voire
d'intimidant accomplissez vous dit
bonsoir
présentez vous demander à la personne
qu'elle est son prénom
donnez-lui quelques pièces donnez-lui
dans la main et touché sa main même si
c'est sale métro est encore plus
dégueulasse que la main d'un sdf
mettez l'argent dans sa main dites lui
au revoir et d'être le dis plus bon
courage parce que pour dormir ce soir
dans la rue à paris sans péter les
plombs
sans aller à braquer le premier petit
magasin à côté de chez vous sans
agresser des gens dans la rue son volet
des petites vieilles faut avoir du
courage il faut vous imaginer la
solidité morale et éthique qu'il faut
avoir quand on est dans cette situation
là pour pas devenir violent souhaité
leur bon courage et vous en allez ça ne
vous appris que 25 secondes de plus que
d'habitude mais je peux vous dire deux
choses premièrement pour avoir parlé
avec un grand nombre de sans abri je
peux vous dire ça les touche et c'est
extrêmement important
ça laisse une trace chez eux ça laissera
une trace chez vous est peut-être que
comme mon étudiante vous irez vous
coucher en ayant une pensée pour les
personnes en situation d'exclusion
le timer clignote et j'aimerais vous
laisser sur une pensée un cric avait
poussé l'abbé pierre le 1er février 1954
et qui malheureusement pour être poussé
aujourd'hui mes amis au secours
une femme vient de mourir je laisse
cette nuit à 3 heures sur le trottoir du
boulevard sébastopol serrant sur elle le
pape hier par lequel avant-hier on avait
expulsé
chaque nuit ils sont plus de 2000
recroquevillée sous le gel sans toit
sans pain plus d'un presque nue
la météo annonce à moi de jeu les
terribles tant que durant l'hiver devant
leurs frères mourant de misère une seule
opinion doit exister entre hommes
la volonté de rendre impossible que cela
dure je vous prie aimons-nous assez tout
de suite pour faire cela devant leurs
frères mourant de misère une seule
opinion doit exister entre les hommes la
volonté de rendre impossible que cela
dure je vous prie aimons-nous passer
tout de suite pour faire cela merci
[Applaudissements]